welcome to our panel on adapting to
climate change when a welcoming
the University of the Earth Institute
and the International Research Institute
on climate and society which are our
sponsors here tonight my name is Steve
Cohen I'm executive director of the
Earth Institute and a professor at the
School of International public affairs
so first I'll talk about what we're
doing here and then I'll introduce our
distinguished panel Hurricane Sandy's
unprecedented impact on this region is
still being felt today months after the
storm has passed the storm resulted in a
massive response effort that continues
today and involved every level of
government along with an impressive
outpouring of private help it's now
clear that it's going to take a long
time to recover from this disaster
anybody who looks at the South Ferry
train station can tell you that that's
going to be the case unlike the response
to Katrina though we've seen an intense
and and i would say reasonably competent
government response but to this disaster
but the scale of the disaster the scale
the impact means that people will
continue to suffer continue today and
until life resumes its normal rhythms in
this region people are going to complain
and those complaints need to be heard
and government has to continue to
mobilize for response as we work to
transition to a fossil fuel free economy
which is really what's going to solve
this problem and begin reversing the the
causes of climate change we will still
need to adapt to the impact of the
climate change already underway that's
really what we're going to be talking
about tonight for the most part that
does not mean we're going to abandon
living near coasts i should say with a
city with 500 miles of coastline i don't
think we're going to be heading for the
hills there's only so much room here on
Morningside Heights anyway and as near
as I can tell most of the apartments are
already full so we're going to need to
continue to live on our coast and I
think people want to do that the risk of
disaster doesn't mean that we're going
to abandon our
communities it's not clear if we look at
this nationally that any area is out of
is away from risk whether you talk about
drought in the Midwest or fires and the
West potential for other kinds of
natural disasters there is really no
place to hide we have to figure out a
way to reduce and mitigate climate
change and to adapt to the change that's
underway it means we have to develop
more resilient homes and infrastructure
and a more robust national program of
emergency response and insurance and of
course we really have to address the
basic issue of climate change however
it's not only climate change that's
causing this vulnerability the world's
population continues to grow at urbanize
America's population continues to grow
that means that storms that at one point
might have passed by a population now
we'll hit that population that
population would be bigger today than it
was 50 or 100 years ago we're also more
dependent on power than we once wore in
our lifestyles many of the technologies
their central to the way we live require
energy when the electricity stops and
the heat goes off and the sewage system
stops working in the water system stops
working normal routines are disrupted
this means that we've got to modernize
our grid we have to modernize our
infrastructure and we have to work to
build a more decentralized or
distributed system of power generation
and storage but again that's really not
the subject for tonight tonight's panel
focuses on the use of science the
scientific information to help us manage
our cities and facilitate our response
to these kinds of emergencies science
and technology has given us the gift of
our modern way of life but but it's also
given us the curse of pollution and
climate change my view is that we're
going to need science and technology to
help us manage our way to a sustainable
and renewable economy and tonight's
panel will explore the use of scientific
information to adapt to climate change
what scientific information
has helped us already what information
is available but not used what kind of
scientific information that we still
need to develop so that's going to be
the subject of our panel I am really
pleased to introduce to you the panel
tonight I should say that everybody has
on their seats bios of everyone so I'm
not going to go through everything about
our panel except to say the first person
here you were to see is Adam Sobel who
is professor of applied physics and
applied mathematics and is also
professor of Earth environmental
sciences and as a member of Lamont's
division of ocean and climate physics so
welcome Adam seated next to him is dr.
Lisa Goddard who is the director of the
International Research Institute for
climate society and an adjunct professor
within the department of earth of
environmental sciences as well and
seated all the way at the end here is a
doctor Sergey panofsky who is the
director of New York City's mayor's
office of long-term planning and
sustainability which oversees the city's
comprehensive sustainability initiative
plan NYC he also happens to teach at the
school of international public affairs
in his spare time and so I want to
welcome the panel and let's start off
with the first question that I'd like
everybody to address she's hurricane
sandy and the extreme weather in 2012
has reinvigorated interest in applying
climate change science to urban and
disaster planning how are we currently
integrating climate change data into
planning for the future what do we
currently know that isn't effectively
being used in that loose plans so I'll
start with Adam and we'll work our way
down the panel
so I don't I haven't read all the
adaptation plans that are out there but
my sense is that we're still at the
beginning of actually using climate
information in in planning for the
future in the sense that when it comes
to disasters I mean we have a sense you
know floods like sandy we have a sense
of what the historical references are we
have flood maps for example that are
based on the one in a hundred year flood
or or some other metric like that that's
based on historical events but when it
comes to when it comes to larger scale
climate variability and especially
anthropogenic climate change my sense is
that in some places like New York City
there's been a fair amount of effort
paid to understanding what that's going
to mean locally they've been reports
written about how climate change is
going to affect the city but i'm not
sure if and maybe a surgery kind of
address this more effectively than i can
but i'm not sure if it's really been
used that much in the sense of actually
affecting a decision about anything
that's actually you know has anything
actually changed yet because of a
climate change projection i'm not sure i
think there's a heightened awareness now
and there was before sandy and it's even
higher now in this city's and the
leaders in that but whether whether this
real decisions have been made accounting
for what we know is going to happen in
the future i don't know an example of
that is the new fema flood risk maps
which what's said about them is that
they don't account for sea level rides
yet although i might take on it is that
maybe they sort of do even though
they're not saying it but that's an
example of where i think the information
isn't yet there Lisa the IRI is one of
its main purpose is actually to take
climate information and bring it to
decision-makers so what's your take on
this question I like Adam I'm also
interested to hear what Sergei has to
say about what New York is actually
doing but more broadly in communities
there's really two types of information
that are regularly being used about the
future one is just weather forecasts so
that's not quite in that climate realm
and then there's climate change
projections and so right now I would say
for most people most decision-makers the
future is synonymous with whatever the
climate change projections say and I
agree with that what adam says that
there has been a lot of awareness that's
been raised from these such as the
robustness of sea level rise at least
that it globally will rise the
temperatures will get warmer and in many
parts of the world were more likely to
experience extreme events but I think
what's missing from our plans of the
future is a more holistic view of
climate the fact that climate
variability is a really important part
of the planning and climate varies on a
lot of different time scales and we are
going to get to climate change one year
at a time and so we need to bring
climate variability and climate change
together so i think that the things that
we already know that could be better
used in planning has to do with
historical risks and for example
seasonal climate forecasts which will
help us in at least our short term
planning sorry what's your take thanks
Oh Steve personal thanks for having us
up here this is what a timely topic the
how you integrate really scientific for
guests with risk management and utility
Planning and infrastructure planning I
like to take a step back and just think
for a second about New York City really
is a marvel of engineering when you
think about for a second the fact that
we have you know the oldest and densest
utility networks public transport
networks and a water system that
basically takes water that flows by
gravity from further north and brings
water down here one of the lowest carbon
footprints and generally a system that
works very well but you know the the you
know it's our responsibility of every
generation I think to be good caretakers
of this endowment and also to think hard
about new ways of doing things as well
and I think you know New Yorkers are
innovators the fact that we have 530
miles of coastline is obviously a great
challenge as we saw during sandy I think
if you look back you know the question
has climate science
embodied in the city government
operations or the way that city
government thinks about things I think
you turn back the clock back to two
thousand six on the mayor really
convened all the city agencies for to
create play NYC in 2007 and really the
goal was to accommodate a million more
people and make the city greener more
sustainable and more resilient also and
I think really the mayor bloomberg
really set the course sir I think was
one of the few cities really to take
that you know deep dive really across
different classes of infrastructure in
fact I think the first city in the US
and I think what came of it and I'm
talking now all pre-sandy there's a lot
to be discussed about what we're doing
now in the wake of Sandy but the climate
change adaptation task force was really
brought together because of that and
what that was was a and still is a
really a group of all the major
infrastructure operators from MTA to the
utilities to really look at cost benefit
analysis of raising infrastructure
handling different types of climate
risks the New York City panel on climate
change itself has has been informing our
and will be informing you know some of
our capital investment decisions of
cost-benefit analysis we have reconvened
that panel in the wake of Sandy if you
look at for example DPS green
infrastructure plan I really the plan YC
philosophy is really embedded there if
you look at what deputy mayor Holloway
and Commissioner Strickland have done
their relates an idea to have an
adaptive strategy and really build
passive systems with you know low energy
footprint to really absorb increased
precipitation and you're reducing sewer
overflows and really doing in a way
saving money by not just building
traditional gray infrastructure only if
you look at our energy policy has really
focused on reliability particularly
after the Long Island City blackout
we're looking soup to nuts at ways of
making the city more interconnected with
with its neighbors from an energy
infrastructure perspective increasing
you know the ability to have black star
capabilities to and other means to have
more resilient
network looking at cogeneration
opportunities in city government assets
energy efficiency so it in my view I
think it's already been there in a way
and it's going to accelerate more now
after sandy so we the mayor has convened
something called the special initiative
on recovery and resilience which is
really a citywide effort right now to
understand three things one what really
happened during sandy really taking a
deep dive across the city looking at you
know coastal communities affected
looking at different classes of
infrastructure so one what happened and
bit and quantifying it number two what
might happen and this is where the New
York City panel climate change is
actually weighing in and revising their
earlier recommendations from a couple of
years ago on both chronic and extreme
events so sea level rise and when heat
waves and surge so what might happen you
don't want to just fight the last war
and then third what we're going to have
a set of recommendations both for
policymakers and regulators and and also
for city agencies on what are
cost-effective measures to to deal with
extreme weather and climate
contingencies going forward so one of
the questions I guess I'd like to turn
to then is
is there climate science that we have
that could be used that's still on the
Shelf that we haven't applied yet I mean
trying to bring science into the
decision-making process as i can tell
you or sarah you can tell you is a
complicated issue but as scientists and
I'll start with you Adam is there some
information or some analysis that you
think we need to do a better job of
bringing to Sergey of his colleagues
yeah I think I mean a broader point that
I think is worth making is that climate
change is going to pose a lot of
different risks we know their
temperatures going to go up
precipitation patterns are going to
change have more floods and more
droughts storms are probably to change
sea level rise is going to go up but
there's a very different levels of
uncertainty on those different
projections some things we're very
confident about the temperature going up
is one and it'll go up pretty much
everywhere with almost no exceptions and
we know with some uncertainty how much
but the uncertainty is bigger than we
like it to be but it's it's it's what it
is and it definitely rules out some
possibilities on the low end of the high
end so I think on the one hand we have
to be aware of the the high risk events
like sandy that we can't quantify the
risk all that precisely we don't know
how the changes with that much precision
how much more frequent they're going to
be in the future or how much in more
intense but then there's some things we
are very confident about and I don't
think we're using that information as as
well as we could one example that's
relevant not directly to New York City
but I think you could probably say
something similar here but this is about
the Sahel region of Africa some of our
colleagues here just did a study this is
michaela be associate lamont and michael
gerard at center for climate change law
and a couple of their associates just
did a study where they looked at the
adaptation plans of countries in the
Sahel region of Africa this is West
Africa region that's very vulnerable to
drought historically and famine and
looked at the adaptation plans that the
countries in that region have made to as
a basis for getting adaptation funding
that would be distributed through the UN
and other mechanism so the question they
asked was how is climate science being
used in what these countries are saying
they need to do
to prepare for climate change and what
they found was that the the plans by and
large were based on adapting to what's
currently the most the biggest hazard in
the current climate which is natural
variability in rainfall creating
droughts in some years so currently the
big risk for agriculture in this region
of Africa is drought and so there's
droughts every so often sometimes they
can last for several years or even ten
years and that could be very
catastrophic and so precipitation is the
problem for agriculture and the plans
reflected that what we know is that in
the future the temperature will be
higher than anything those countries
have been any is true of worldwide but
the temperature is going to be higher
than anything that's been experienced in
those places and the agricultural
scientists know that temperature is
going to become the dominant problem for
agriculture the crops are going to die
do you heat and the plans don't account
for that because that isn't been the
problem in the past the other thing they
don't Aquino pretty well almost as well
as that is that the precipitation
although the amount of precipitation
over a season may change but it's not
going to change outside of the bounds of
anything that's happened in the past
probably in that region whereas
temperature will and the other thing
that will happen is that the
precipitation although it may be
comparable in amount throughout the
season on average maybe more or less on
average but in the same range it'll be
burst years there'll be more high
precipitation events possibly fewer
events with higher rainfall leading to
more flooding and we pretty confident
about that those are the two things we
know with the most certainty will be
different in the future and because
they're out a sample I mean because they
isn't within the range of natural
variability the the plans really didn't
account for that and so that's an
example where the current climate
science really isn't being used and what
the people who did this study describe
it is that that it could be getting
ahead of the curve based on the science
but instead they're adapting to the
problems of past and I think that if we
look at I suspect that that conclusion
generalizes beyond the Sahel that just
happens to be where the study was Lisa
what do you think what science should we
be bringing to our decision makers that
why don't you kind of like to follow up
on on some of Adam's
I think it's relevant to what what I
would have said anyway because
especially in developing countries like
in regions of the Sahel the variability
is critical and so it's it's maybe not
just a matter of you know why aren't
these countries responding to something
that we we are pretty sure is going to
happen by the end of the 21st century
because if if their crops fail because
of drought in the next 10 years it's
really not going to matter to them if it
goes up three degrees 50 years from now
and so it's it's extremely important I
think to put that information and this
is this is where science actually can
inform things is is actually to play a
more participatory role in the
conversations to have an open ear to
what the issues are the people need to
adapt to I think you know it's not just
developing countries even here sandy
we're not adapted to the current climate
we have all sorts of issues with the
current climate a lot of the things that
Sergei was laying out actually were
resiliency issues resiliency efforts
that are helping us cope with the
current situation for a lot of places if
you can cope with the current situation
and you're starting to anticipate what's
going to happen in the next year the
next couple years then your incremental
e becoming better prepared for how
climate change is likely to play out I
also will acknowledge that there are
plenty of decisions and plenty of
infrastructure and policy decisions that
absolutely need to be informed by the
you know 50 to 100 year time scale but
not all of them and not for all
decision-makers I think that's this just
a really important point to make and so
you know again i'm putting this plug for
for variability in combination with
change because climate change is a
problem now but variability is also a
problem now and will also be a problem
in the future sergei let me let me pose
the question to you in a slightly
different way
okay which is to say what kind of
science information do you know this out
there that you wish you could figure out
some way to bring into the
decision-making process and you know I
know a lot about this is making
processes to in fact scientists think
that there that we actually have a
rational marched decisions until there's
an answer and in fact what happens in
the policy process is we're just trying
to make things less bad and and that the
process making things less bad we
sometimes when information but sometimes
we just do not have any because sort of
what you don't know can't hurt you but
let me just put the question to you what
kind of science information would you
like to have yeah let's do you think you
for that I think our administration is
very data-driven and science driven we
want the science to lead I think the way
the way I look at it if you look at
across infrastructure classes in New
York City to me it seems that the
climate risks right now are not really
included in the regulatory frameworks
that that govern energy telecom and
other critical infrastructures so right
now there there is not a clear road map
at the regulatory level and so we can
talk about specific types of data that
would be needed and which ones are there
or not but I think one of the one of the
insights I think is that you know
regulators tend to look at costs rather
than performance so how do you one of
the challenges is how do you say well in
order to mitigate this risk should I
spend a hundred million dollars to spend
a billion dollars on it so I think you
need to put in the cost-benefit
framework and I think the climate
science community and the what is a very
mature risk management industry and the
utilities and infrastructure operators
they need to speak each other's
languages and I think that we're seeing
that start to happen but it's not quite
there yet and I think that's one of the
reasons that regulators struggle to
figure out exactly what price tag to put
on an investment that would mitigate
against some type of risk so they want
to see better confidence intervals and
more more the kind of work up that they
normally include in their types of
analysis so that's that's an area that
we need to see more
progress on do you writing notes you
have something you want to add to that
yeah I mean I was really thinking about
the different question which about what
you know that I just thinks there's a
couple good points I mean about the
better confidence intervals I mean I
think we the sort of we're here in some
sense a lot of people are here anyway
although you planned this before sandy
that some people are probably here
because of Sandy and and that's so these
kind of extreme events are poster
children for for climate change whether
or not a particular event has any
climate change signal in it doesn't
almost doesn't matter it brings all our
attention to to the risks that we are
facing and so the rare events are really
important I mean although there are a
lot of different ways will feel climate
change and climate variability this is
actually right about that but but even
in the present climate we're under risk
for extreme events and whether in the
president of future climate the extreme
events are what we are going to be the
most harmful and I think the the risks
of extreme events are where the climate
science can improve constantan proves
still because the there are some kinds
of extreme events that our climate
projections can handle reasonably well
tempered heat waves and droughts we have
the climate models are somewhat capable
of doing those normal rainfall driven
floods maybe the hurricanes and
tornadoes were still not great at
hurricanes and getting better tornadoes
the long way off before we can say what
the risks are with climate change and
even in the present climate because the
rare events are sufficiently rare that
we haven't been around long enough to
observe the worst ones in many places we
don't even really know you know what is
the one in five hundred year storm we
don't know because we haven't had
records for 500 years that are good
enough so I think you know that better
confidence intervals and it's not just
the scientific knowledge but the ability
to express it in the right language I
think that's true there's a climate
change science and there's a sort of
disaster
risk management effort that are starting
to communicate now and you saw and I
think the media public discussion after
sandy how those were starting to get
combined in a way that I think reflects
in part the work done by the npcc and
Cynthia Rosa wives groupid gifts and and
others in making bringing the the
government and decision-makers together
with with the science for about a decade
I think you're starting to see that
coming together but there are different
languages and we scientists get a little
bit better at at speaking that language
and saying what we know we don't know
exactly what the uncertainties are doing
factors here is that the insurance
industry the insurance business is a
huge business and you know in order to
operate an economy of most businesses
try to insure against these kinds of
catastrophe so they can continue to
operate and so in essence you have a
whole business that's based on these
bets about what the future is going to
look like and so it's clear that that's
a group of people that has a market for
the information that we might provide
now I know I RI is actually been working
on the issue of crop insurance for that
reason I don't know if you want to talk
a little bit about that Lisa yeah we've
been doing quite a bit actually and this
year I would say is a breakthrough this
year in Ethiopia was the first time ever
that there's been a large-scale payout
to small small holder farmers on climate
based index insurance this is a program
that I our eyes involved with its under
Oxfam involves swiss re it also involves
the the national meteorological service
in Ethiopia but it brings in
as well the local disaster agencies and
credit agencies and insurance companies
in the region so there has been some
drought in in Ethiopia this year and i
believe over 12,000 farmers were
reimbursed for their losses over 320,000
US dollars and that's really
unprecedented there have been some index
based insurance payouts had been on
small pilot levels before but this is a
project that we've been involved with
for some time started I believe in 2009
there are about 200 200 farmers involved
in just one village and now that's grown
within in northern Ethiopia it's grown
up in Ethiopia as a whole to about
18,000 farmers and 76 villages and now
it's going to be some a lot of that same
sort of model is going to be transferred
to Senegal so this is something that can
really help remove a lot of the the risk
and the poverty traps that exist in
rain-fed agriculture regions sir is it
nice to hear about a population we don't
have to worry about farmers in new york
city to bring the question a little bit
more into a somewhat higher plane the
this issue of insurance and this issue
of risk and in essence how does a city
like this with 500 miles of coastline
deal with these real public policy
issues of how much risk do we ask the
private marketplace to assume how much
does a city and state is soon and then
to what extender we really dependent on
the whole national community and how do
we think about this that's a huge
challenge and I think the report that i
mentioned we're going to be publishing
that in May and if you look at for
example across infrastructure classes in
some cases DEP is a municipal utility so
city government has
you know jurisdiction of that in the
case of con Edison and and and national
grab those are private utilities and so
state regulators ultimately determine
what the what the rate payers will pay
and so you if you just look across did
you know in buildings and we have
discretion of our building codes and
then so so you know across measures you
have different entities from federal
state to local that have jurisdiction if
you look at for example the we had a
liquid fuels problem during during the
hurricane well that supply chain 75% of
supply chains outside of New York City
refineries from Philadelphia New Jersey
up through terminals and barges and
pipelines that come ultimately here so
that's why we have I think a very close
federal interface on this because it's
going to require some cases of regional
solutions but we're still working on a
lot of the recommendations particular on
coastal coastal protection measures
those are you know we're looking
literally everything is on the table and
I think in May it's too early for me to
to say exactly what you know conclusions
that reports going to have but I think
you're going to see a very comprehensive
report looking across all classes
infrastructure Adam what's your take on
this risk issue for for our coastal
communities in the places like New York
um I don't know I really don't know what
to do about it it's a above my pay grade
I there you know his I think it's good
to put in perspective that the place if
you look at the places that flooded in
sandy and where historically there were
wetlands they're pretty much the same
and so that tells you that's a good
place to start now of course we're not
they're not gonna all go back to being
wetlands it's not going to happen I mean
the cities is too too far along its path
for that to happen but but somehow we
have to rent we have to recognize the
fact that water's going to get there
sometime and do something about that so
the insurance could probably be more you
know better reflect the risks that are
there and could probably be more widely
used a lot of people that you know could
have flood insurance and business is
probably too that could have flood
insurance it that don't but a lot of
it's probably gonna have to be
engineering of some kind whether you
know so you have building codes
insurance zoning sea walls all these
things that some have higher cost than
others but I think yeah we have to do
the cost-benefit analysis and that has
to take into account what the risks are
as accurately as we know them now and in
the future so one of the criticisms of
sea walls which i think is absolutely
true is that sooner or later with enough
sea level rise it will be effective
anymore you'll have to keep them closed
all the time and then the river roll
back up and it won't become unmanageable
so there's a period of time where they'd
probably work and then beyond that they
won't and so we have to decide what time
frame we're thinking on and not get
complacent if we go for big engineering
solutions like that the race is the
overall issue that
I remember the first time I heard about
climate adaptation people who wanted to
mitigate climate change said no we
should not even talk about climate
adaptation because that is really almost
blast it means that we've given up we've
accepted defeat and we're going to
tolerate all this stuff so we'll start
with lisa is that something we should
really be paying attention to is that
are these two irreconcilable issues we
can only deal with one at a time um I
think we absolutely need to deal with
with both and I think you're sort of
setting it up for that yeah we're
changing the the planet in irreversible
ways and it's it's not just increasing
greenhouse gases but that's a big part
of it and that's something that we need
to to do something about that something
with that I think with better science
throughout the sciences so we could do
something about but at the same time
climate is changing and it's we're
already experiencing some of the effects
of that and I'll come back to the issue
of climate holistically that we need to
be adapting to climate period the fact
that New York City has experienced
storms of the magnitude that sandy
brought in the past and maybe it didn't
lead to the same sort of economic and
financial losses back in the 30s I guess
it was that it did today because there
were less people and there wasn't
internet and as much communication and
is as much wealth but just because we
have growing populations and growing
infrastructure and a whole lot of a
whole lot more demand on our planet as a
whole we need to adapt to climate so
adaptation is
is not a debatable topic and it's not an
either/or so just because you're
adapting doesn't mean that that's a pass
on doing something serious about
mitigation and energy policy sir how did
look in City Hall I mean this was one of
the biggest emergencies that this
administration had to deal with and it
was 24 7 for how long is this issue of
climate adaptation now part of the
routine of city government is this sort
of like you know getting the salt ready
for a snowstorm that's a very good
question i think that i think the answer
is yes i think it's getting there I
think you know obviously we've had a lot
to say about mitigation the city had an
obviously very ambitious plan of city
government having a thirty percent
reduction target by 2017 and citywide by
2030 we're already we've already reduced
our carbon footprint by sixteen percent
within city wide so i think that's
already a tremendous you know
achievement we're also doing getting
back to your question about you know is
it adaptation or mitigation i think it's
both we launched a study last year and
we're going to write we're wrapping that
up right now looking at is it possible
to actually reduce carbon emissions by
eighty percent by 2050 and you know
before the storm most of our
stakeholders we're interested in one
thing and after the storm we got a lot
of questions on well shouldn't it be all
about adaptation should we be even
spending a dollar and mitigation and i
think i think you have to look at both
and in many cases are actually some
projects can bring you multiple benefits
when you're looking at it really when
you ask the fundamental question about
how do you modernize a system these are
really relevant questions to ask and it
has to go through that process so i
think i think the answer is you got to
do both
yeah i mean about adaptation risk
mitigation i mean that the the notion
that talking about adaptation means
we're giving up is just either it's
partly true in a sense but it's also
just reflecting reality i mean the the
even if we were to radically cut carbon
emissions now beyond anything that
anybody thinks is politically feasible
we've already seen some anthropogenic
warming probably a little more than half
a degree and we'll see a little bit more
just because the carbons in the system
is going to stay there for a while so
the even under the most optimistic
scenarios there's some warming more
realistically where you know at the high
end now of what the projections were in
the last IPCC report in 2007 so we're
gonna see some warming and and it's just
unrealistic not to recognize that but
also i mean the problem of i think we
have to be more realistic about the
politics of it i mean what we know shun
that adapting then we were giving up on
mitigation dated from a time when people
still had a great a deal of optimism
about the international negotiation
process around climate change i mean we
all have our hopes for it but it hasn't
done too well so far and and the problem
is ultimately it's a problem of the
commons right we all have to reduce
carbon in order for anybody to benefit
and so what we're finding is that the
most effective action the most of the
players were able to do the most on this
problem are low at the local level like
here in New York where where we've seen
such leadership from this administration
and and the city and this and the system
and a few other places in the United
States and around the world as well but
that's at a smaller level and there's
just nothing that regions of that size
can do that by itself will make a huge
dent in the carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere we can we can and should do
it but it's because we're being good
citizens I mean wait it's not because if
New York City reduces its carbon
footprint by thirty percent it's going
to change our climate it's going to make
no difference but we have to do it
because if it because everybody has to
do it but so but adaptation we can do
for ourselves and that will make a
difference in life here and so I think
we know
I think it's interesting I mean the
politics of climate is always something
I'm interested in its that as a public
policy problem it's really a tough one
because it's created everywhere and its
impact is in the future and our
political system doesn't do well with
those kinds of problems now fortunately
there is the low-hanging fruit that New
York City's already grabbed for which is
most of the reduction in greenhouse
gases has been done through energy
efficiency there it's very hard to argue
that we should waste energy and spend
more money on it so the first twenty or
thirty percent that we're getting is
coming from those gains in fact as you
were saying the bigger gains are going
to have to come from something more
systemic technological or global my own
bet would be on technological I I don't
think there's going to be a global
treaty but I don't know sir j what do
you think will be a global trees I'm not
going to comment on that no idea but it
mean to go to your point I think there
are some investment like energy
efficiency which helps you not only
adaptive heat waves but also can there's
a value proposition for building owners
to do that so it helps you on both sides
so I agree with you let me ask one more
question the panel before I ask for the
audience to give us some questions and
see what you really would like to hear
about my question is if we had a blank
slate and endless funding what science
should we be working on that would help
on this issue there's now we're and
first I want to hear what what your own
or grown groups which should do and what
our scientists should do and then Sergey
can tell us what would be helpful to the
decision makers so Adam we'll start with
you and then I'll ask Lisa um right so I
certainly think there's a lot of science
to be done in extreme events
understanding what the risks are from
extreme events i think we've only begun
to do that if you read the IPCC report
there's a very lot of very quantitative
information about how the temperature
might change depending what carbon
dioxide does
and even though we don't know the answer
precisely there's big arrow bar but we
know what the error bar is and with
extreme events it's much more
qualitative statements done by very very
isolated groups of scientists many of
whom are in the case of hurricanes and
tornadoes are coming out of the
operational weather prediction community
and are very well integrated into
climate and so we're just I think
beginning to really think seriously in
the last few years about the risks of
extreme events and we're never going to
know you know what we're gonna have a
hurricane of some magnitude ten or a
hundred years from now but we can I
think we can estimate the risks better
than we have and I think we need to do
that in order to make proper
cost-benefit assumptions I think I don't
think we're going to be able to pin down
the climate sensitivity that much better
than we are now I mean we've been
working hard at saying how much warmer
it's going to get in other words how
much warmer will be a hundred years from
now given some reasonable assumptions
about carbon we know that with some
uncertainty that hasn't changed in many
years I don't think we're going to get
that much better on that in the near
term but sea level rise which is very
big one for coastal cities I think the
thinking on sea level rise has evolved
tremendously in just the last few years
and so I think there's still some hope
that we could get a better handle on
that I mean there's a very very wide
range of estimates and at this point we
have to just sort of say well we should
prepare for the worst but that's not
very satisfying I'm you know could it be
a footer could be six feet I mean this
somewhere in there and in a hundred
years I think we could probably do
better on that decato variability I
don't know at least I'll talk about the
game
should be working on that sure I'll talk
about the kid to be out of here look
look before I do though would you say
that I think that preface my answer with
any the development of any climate
information that's it's going to be
useful and is actually going to make a
difference in people's decisions really
needs to be thought about in context
what's the problem who are you talking
to what can they actually realistically
do about it that being said I think that
there's still a number of outstanding
challenges in the climate community as a
whole and having better understanding of
better tools to work with makes those
context related conversations and
information development just that much
easier so just across the board in
climate sciences i would say inseparable
is the need for observations climate
climate scale observations right now
what we take our weather observations
any climate observations we need better
modeling and we need to test those
things out in a predictive setting and I
think that those three things go
together you take one of those legs away
from the stool and it's going to fall
over right now the u.s. is investing in
all three of these things but I don't
think it is sufficient level that we're
really moving forward and definitely not
moving forward to the degree that we
need to and I think last year is a
really perfect example of that so I
would hope that with sufficient
investment we would be building better
climate models a higher resolution that
are informed by good observations so
that we're better capturing the the
dynamic and thermodynamic processes in
the models we need to get those physical
processes right so that we actually have
some confidence and what those models
are telling us and at when we need to
come down to a much smaller resolution
in order to really faithfully represent
those and even so some processes won't
be resolved but even if we're getting
the processes spot on there will still
be uncertainty and models and so having
better models is not necessarily going
to ensure
that we have perfectly accurate
information but what we'll do is give us
a much better sense of what the true
uncertainty is in that information and
from that we can get a better idea of
the risks so I would advocate for really
a very loved this word holistic tonight
excuse me for using it about 50 times
but holistic perspective on climate
science because i really think that
these three pieces need to go together
to produce a strong body of information
so the way i would pose the question for
you Serge's and watching the city
respond to sandy frankly a lot of it was
very impressive emergency responders
first responders were saved lots of
lives the subways were moved to higher
ground the buses were moved to higher
ground City got most of the city got up
in money pretty quickly the biggest
problems in the five boroughs other than
on the shore front work the electrical
problems in lower Manhattan but in
general you have to say New York City
did pretty well during this but the
question I would the way I would pose
the question is what kind of scientific
information would have helped the city
better prepare and better respond to
what happened last year I mean this is a
fundamental question about how science
filters into the decision-making process
and I think looking at long term I think
you know obviously billions of dollars
of scarce capital are in question on
whether you going to spend them and this
kind of investment of that kind of
investment moving forward there's always
a risk to over or under investing or
investing in the wrong thing so I think
this is a this is really the key
question as you know we've been working
with FEMA on updating the new flood maps
and the last iteration of it was really
the 1983 vintage vintage map I think the
new advisors just came out recently and
if you look at if you overlay the the
100-year flood zone on any of the key
pieces of infrastructure depending on
what climate science yields as far as
sea level rise overlay you're going to
have a very different investment
paradigm
another potentially and so I think that
that whole process is is it is
incredibly important as I look at a
couple of in the New York City panel
climate change has has obviously been
helping us tremendously and to
understand that but I think as we move
forward there's some other some other
areas that we probably need as I said
there's wide confidence intervals for
sea level rise we need to understand
that a little bit better I think wind
projections those are those storm
frequency those those will be important
a more granular quantitative analysis of
heavy rainfall so not just per day but
by power in some cases that impacts some
systems and you know we can can have a
list of things that I think are not
necessarily easy to model humidity
projections that impacts how how heat
waves impact peak load so but i would
say you know as far as what kind of
information the city's gone if you look
at for example DP they have some we call
the operation support tool where they
look at the whole system of reservoirs
and where to release water and so forth
they use on a daily basis and I don't
know if you call it meteorological more
weather type forecasts or longer-term I
don't know where that exact cut off is
but that's part of the lifeblood of that
agency because they have to worry about
turbidity events they have to worry
about droughts in particular and so I
think I think it is in many ways
something that that we focus on very
closely but moving forward as i said i
think the the language of the different
communities from risk management and
science have to come a little bit closer
together and there's a couple i'd say a
short list of predict you know metrics
that I think we need a better handle on
some that we haven't yet produced in
other cases we just need a more
quantitative analysis to really put the
put the put the probably probabilistic
element to it that we don't have it just
yet thank you okay so I want to turn to
a different part of our discussion where
I'm going to
entertain questions from the audience
let me make a couple of points before we
start first of all we're not looking for
comments or debate we have some experts
here I'd like to tap into what they have
to say so if you raise your hand we have
people with microphones who will come
and and recognize you guys will start in
the back there there's a question just
tell us who you are and if you want to
say anything else about yourself but
just please ask a question take the
microphone Thanks hi I'm Daniella I'm a
student here at Columbia College in the
sustainable development program and dr.
Cohen you introduced the panel by
referencing the need to move away or to
move to a fossil fuel free economy and
also as a climate mitigation strategy
what do you you or any of the panelists
think about the current national
movement of more than 256 schools
demanding for our administration's to
divest our endowments from funding the
fossil fuel industry including here at
Columbia okay anybody want to take that
up Adam you look ready yeah it's an
interesting question I was in another
event here post-sandy and it same
question gotta ask tonight and I didn't
answer it somebody else answered it and
I agreed with their answer and then more
I thought about the more I came to a
different conclusion my first thought
was that when I first heard this raised
was that it it didn't make a lot of
sense to me because you know we can I
think those of us on the left side of
the political spectrum which includes
pretty much every scientist that works
on this for better or worse I mean let's
be honest be honest the yeah I mean we
you know we we have you know we have may
think
we have may have our thoughts about
who's more or less responsible for the
situation that we're in but you know we
all are burning fossil fuels we wouldn't
be here if we weren't you know so I
think we were all complicit in the
situation and so my first thought when I
heard about this divestiture thing well
that doesn't make sense because we can't
really blame the oil companies for
giving us what we are paying them for
right but actually I've come to think
about it differently I think the issue
is that you know the debate about
climate change which is a kind of
manufacturer debate at this point that's
really reminiscent of the one that was
about smoking in the 70s where the
tobacco companies invested a lot of
money and fake studies to discredit the
notion that smoking would kill you is
you know similar the oil companies some
of them at least have been involved in
supporting a disinformation campaign
that has not helped anything and I think
it's that that justifies thinking about
tactics like that the fact that there's
you know burning mining fossil fuels and
selling them to us I think we're all
responsible for that not just the oil
companies but the fact that they're
creating a false debate about the
science some some people and I think
some of the energy companies are
responsible for helping to create a
false debate about science in lieu of
the real debate we should be having
which is what to do about it I mean we
know what's happening with the climate
to first approximation we just know what
to do and there's a legitimate political
debate to be had there where different
people can have different views about it
and that's the debate that we should
have and there's room for views on all
sides the political spectrum about that
but we're not entitled to the different
facts and different side of the
political spectrum and I think that's
that that's where you know I think
efforts like this might be able to have
some impact isn't changing that
situation a little bit let's try for
another question over here I see someone
okay yeah hi my name is Roland i worked
with earth day in new york and part of
our initiative among a lot of
environmental things we do is to promote
building community gardens with in
inner-city schools for sergej what sort
of initiatives is in New York City
implementing to promote localizing food
production and the second part food for
thought is so what can we do for the
future to deal with increasing
temperatures and not heart and excuse me
I'm not being able to harvest previously
agrarian land way I'm sorry what was the
second part I didn't hear that how can
we prepare for the future what sort of
things we can do before in what context
for what localizing food production for
localizable so Steve I confess I'm not
the the world's expert in food
production and I come unqualified to
speak about that any death but we are
looking in our report at the if the food
supply chain and resilience related to
it so everything from you know grocery
stores to where food is stored to
resilience measures around that because
you could have had an event that would
have you know if if the moon was at a
different angle you would have had
flooding that happened somewhere else
potentially and there are you know a
small number of food distribution
networks and and so there there is
there's a question an ongoing research
going on within our department looking
at
exactly how food is distributed
delivered and how we can prepare for the
next event okay let's move on to a I see
some people up here have questions mark
I'm in the sustainability management
program this is also a question about
food as well not so much the
distribution of it from distribution
centers in mass manufactured food but
what kind of research you know
specifically to the New York City region
is there going on about food supply dr.
Goddard you talked about in an exciting
project in Ethiopia but you know we've
got a lot of locally grown crops you
know grown in New York New Jersey kinds
of things that you know certainly must
have been impacted by Sandy so what kind
of research is going on or should be
going on to understand the
sustainability of locally sourced food
that is already being grown and
distributed in the area help out a
little bit of this because I actually
had a group of students in the CEPA
program a couple of years ago do a study
for your office on how new york city
gets its food and where it comes from
and what we learned was how complex our
food system is I remember talking to one
of the people who runs the greenmarket
program in the city and I said why
aren't there more of these this is great
and he said well every farmer within 150
miles of new york city of selling
everything they can grow inside the city
of these green markets that in fact and
it still only amounts to less than five
percent of our food supply year I mean
the fact of the matter is it may be sad
to think about it but we are now in a
society where very few of us are
involved in production of food and we're
all dependent on this very complex
global system of food supply so I don't
know if anybody in the panel wants to we
don't have a lot of food experts here
but anybody else want to comment before
we go to another question no okay here's
a act in the front here I see another
question
let's go here hi my name is Joanne
O'Brien I'm a teacher my question is
about protecting groundwater and in
particular fracking in New York State my
concern is that we don't have enough
potable freshwater it's not going to
make a heck of a lot of difference in
terms of food supply so what if anything
is New York doing about protecting our
groundwater and making sure that we have
enough water to have an agricultural
system sir if you wouldn't talk about
our water this is a really a question
for the state which is looking at that
right now but I think the broader
question for us is actually our water
system in New York City is not dependent
on the ground water yes our water is it
comes from you know through the aqueduct
system for the north I think regarding
fracking you know the mayor has as a
public position honor which is that
there are you know obviously tremendous
public policy benefits to natural gas
switching out residual fuel oil for
example number six fuel which produces
you know there's ten thousands of
buildings in the city that burned number
six and four fuel they contribute half
the particular matter emissions in the
city so there's a great value to
displacing that whether its natural gas
biofuels ultra-low sulfur number number
two but the position also is that you
know there had the industry and
government has to come around sensible
best practices and solutions for for
this you know endowment that the the
region in the country country has and so
that's I think I think we need we need
to figure out the best way to produce
that to protect to protect the
environment think that's what's being
looked at particular environmental
defense defense fund spending tremendous
amount of time looking at things like
fugitive emissions and water emissions I
think that's I think we're going to see
a lot of progress in that regard
other questions over here I see someone
who's been trying to get a question from
the start yeah thank you Rick Hirsch
graduate night spent a lot of time on
marine and fish conservation projects
I'm sure you're all busy as can be with
the science and data and keep it up and
it was great to learn that the mayor's
both New York out and from the pack on
and working this issue but my goodness
two days after sandy what a pleasure to
hear the governor I know it's a blue
state but he he i think he said after
Irene and Sandy I hope that the deniers
get pushed into the corner they belong
having said that looking at Washington
from Washington to Copenhagen to Doha
Zippo nada do you have any theories or
ideas on how we as a public or science
or universities can bring at the federal
level this topic more into the center
Adam on you start and that is yeah I
think those of us in this field are all
pretty frustrated at this point I mean
the way the one line of argument a few
years ago is we have to be better at
communicating I'm not convinced that's
the case I think we've communicated what
the problem is pretty clearly I think
there's two at least two problems on a
large scale one is that in the US and
we've had a denialist movement that's
been very well-funded and I think that's
created a lot of problems that are
unique to this country to some extent
the rest of the world is mostly free of
that to the extent that we have it but
the other problem is just that even if
we all agreed about the science that we
come back to the problem at the
international level which is what where
you would need to if you wanted to do
anything in a large-scale about
emissions ultimately you have to get
everybody to do something or at least
all the big players to do something I
mean which is US China and India and few
others and
everybody hopes that somebody else will
bear the cost of it there's going to be
costs no matter what I mean we we have
this question about fracking and that
you know that is an example I mean with
going to natural gas although in the
long term it's still burning carbon but
it'd be cleaner than coal and and other
some other sources and so in the short
term at least you know we should be
doing it but it brings a potential cost
to our region if they're mining the gas
here we don't know exactly how bad it is
but some of us I think are rightfully
scared of it and don't trust studies
have been done thus far they're really
conclusive but that's that's not in my
backyard kind of thing but everything
has cost like that I mean Indian Point
you know we get a lot of a power from
nuclear which is carbon free it's great
right but scares the daylights out of me
I don't I don't um you know you want to
think about disaster scenarios that are
scary for New York City that's that's
one so I think there will be cost of
whatever we do and they're going to have
to be distributed broadly and so it's a
classic game where everybody hopes
somebody else will do it and I think
that's the problem at the international
level at the national level we have a
political debate that's dysfunctional as
we all know you should you want to add
to that I don't think I really can't add
to that I think that was really
exponents ok dirty well let's how much I
can opine on the federal side but I
think what we've tried to do is a city
is to show that it can be done at the
city level yeah it's obviously much more
efficient the larger your geographic
area is so if you have a regional carbon
pool well it's always better to make it
even bigger because you don't want to
have policy leakage and in other
essentially deadweight losses so I think
you know our position is that you know
we've done it we can we can do it here
and I think and we already have a little
carbon footprint and I think the real
selling point is in many cases the value
proposition for many of these
investments make sense if you're for
example leaking fugitive methane from a
wastewater treatment plant well it makes
sense once you utilize that energy
productively once you loop it back in if
you're
if you're you know building envelope is
is is is is not insulating you well well
you know it actually makes sense to make
those energy efficiency investment so I
think in many cases I think what we've
shown hope the show is that is that it
at least a big chunk of the investments
that we've either supported outright or
in a policy standpoint actually makes
sense and so that's you know that's
that's the position we've taken okay I
want to take one more question from that
side and then let me mention that after
the final question I'll make a comment
or two and then we have a lot of
refreshments and the panel is going to
stay here we're going to do informal
conversation so we can chat in small
groups in one-on-one so i hope you some
of you will be able to stay so let me
take one more question from way in the
back there I see somebody's got a
handheld mic anybody over there okay hi
good evening my name is Andrew macore
neck I am a recent grad of the
environmental science and policy program
professor Cohen's program and a question
I have there's a room full of students
and recent graduates here who are really
eager to get involved in these issues in
new york city and beyond and i think
something that some of us have found is
there's just a real slow uptake you know
we're all we all want the green economy
to happen we all want sustainability to
happen but i would love to hear from the
speakers where they think young grads
can really can really have an impact hey
anybody want to start with that
um sure I'll start first of all the
realize that the problem is bigger than
New York City it's a great place to be
but maybe the biggest impact you can
make might be someplace else there's
there's just so much to do I think being
very knowledgeable coming from a strong
scientific understanding no matter what
your your field of study is having a
strong grounding in the facts and
information that you're bringing to the
problem is really important as opposed
to letting your your passion or your
advocacy get the better of the
conversations I think that that's that's
the best thing going into these
conversations but i will say that that
the type of field that that you and a
lot of the people in this room i believe
are in it's really a frontier it's
something new and i think it's something
that a lot of agencies and companies
whether they're private companies or
federal agencies they have an interest
in doing something about climate federal
services has and there's a range of
federal services from from banks to
insurance companies want to do something
about climate and climate change and
they really will admit that they're very
lacking in information but because
they're lacking in information in the
field that you folks are in is new it to
some degree you need to make your own
case you need to be out there making
giving them the vision of what you could
do for what they're what they want to do
because that just hasn't been
articulated in a lot of cases I think
really in a tremendous period right now
I think a lot of the decisions are you
may be made over the next several years
will determine the course of a number of
sectors here for the next couple decades
potentially so I think it's an exciting
time and I was about to say let's talk
in office hours about job prospects
there's that I think you know the kind
of candidates we always look for you
know people who can write well who can
who can think on their feet particularly
few have us it's always good have the
quantitative classes to bolster that
that type of thinking but you know there
are there opportunities and it's a tough
economy but you know hey we always like
to take good interns will oftentimes
become employees but i think you know if
you look at the engineering companies a
lot of them are working on you know real
projects involving both mitigation
adaptation around the world and you know
consultancies etc anyhow we can talk
after class your deputy director is a
graduate of the same program Steve
Caputo you exactly see well okay let me
let me conclude first by thanking
everybody on the panel thank you
and and let me just say that the the
purpose of this kind of discussion is
really to in essence raise the level of
conversation and bring science to bear
and information to bear on what is
sometimes a very contentious debate the
fundamental issue which people were
hinting at here is you know we all use
this energy we all live with it it's
part of how you know the lights are on
us the microphones on us the Internet's
on people are tweeting you know this is
our lifestyle and we didn't we weren't
born into this we came to this because
of things that we value and a style of
life that we want to lead and so the
question of sustainability is really how
do we move from this kind of economy to
the kind of economy that we're really
going to have to develop in order to
survive and I think that one of the
answers is we need decision makers as
informed as a surgery is and we need
scientists as interested in public
policy as the as Lisa and Adam are and
that's a lot of how we're going to solve
this problem so I'm one of those people
who is actually optimistic I think I
started studying environmental policy in
1975 when EPA was five years old and I
think things of many things have gotten
better a few things have gotten worse
but I know that 1975 we couldn't have
seen 300 people sitting here talking
about climate change and I think that's
a sign of progress another sign of
progress is that we have a lot of wine
and beer in the back and other kinds of
refreshments and so I want everybody to
join us and we'll hang out and talk for
a while thanks for coming tonight
you